now why should this be the case and
here's the big idea right
okay so firstly there's just the
calculus reason it's like well that's
just what the numbers tell me okay but
conceptually more importantly remember I
pointed out to you that this is a
rectangle there's a lot of coincidence
okay
what I like you know numerically what
the values of each of the dog but what's
the meaning of each of those numbers
like for example this one what does it
actually signify it signifies a duration
the time that we're interested in a
total right time I should say total what
about the vertical distance the number
is 10 but what does it signify it's the
velocity in this case cuz it's a
distance I'm actually calculating not
velocities but speed right because I'm
it's just that it's just a magnitude
right okay wait a second wait a second
you just worked out time time speed time
time speed speed times time
what is speed times time it's just
distance right now in this case you've
got a simple example a rectangle that's
why you can just do this neatly okay but
when you come back to this this is no
longer a rectangle so that's the point
of integration why is it called
integration because you are putting
together adding up a whole bunch of what
again a whole bunch of infinitesimally
thin rectangles every single one of
which is a little bit of time times a
little bit of speed and another little
bit of time another until whatever you
get is this total area they can have a
weedwacker shape this is convenient
actually it's just a trapezium what
would it look like on this one right
what total displacement does it
represent
you've got a start point right this is
the first half minute whatever you got
an endpoint there
what does this area represent on here
well you need that point up there and a
vertical distance right come on help me
up
this is a trapezium we've heard the
trapezoidal rule right the area of a
trapezium is high onto a plus B what is
it in this case can you tell me it's a
half that's the one times what it's it's
my parallel science right now just be
careful the scales are actually
different here so I've got a two four
six whereas one two three so gotcha
okay so my parallel sides are two and
four that's three right three four five
six three units right so this idea that
every car equals total change right has
to make sense because what you're doing
put away one more time what you're doing
is just an infinite series of speed
times times speed sometimes with just a
little bit to instance of it and that's
why you get total distance right you're
summing you're summing the entire bunch
of distances that travel between time 1
and time 2 or time distant time that
does that make sense so in much the same
way that you when you kind of look at
exponential growth in UK you get a
differential equation right and then
you'd say ok well what if I know the
change in population at a given time
okay and it might be say 500 either been
0.1 or something like that okay how
would you go from this which is a
derivative to the actual population what
would you do
you're gonna integrate you're gonna make
so I'm going to say P equals the
integral off without a little bit up
right then you're going to get out a
function some function of time plus a
constant yes why didn't get this
constant
how can forest go tell us why you get
that constant I just made this number up
right because started from home he could
have started thousands of closed from
home
he's still doing the same thing relative
to his starting point right so what this
represents is you could start anywhere
you like total displacement remember the
distance between distance and
displacement is just comparing your
position relative to starting point does
that make sense so he doesn't care where
you begin he's just looking at well
what's the difference yeah and like I
mentioned before the inner context of a
population you need a particular
population a particular time what would
you need to work out the actual
displacement not just relative to where
you are you just need some position and
some time usually the initial condition
you know when time equals zero
Forest Gump is 20 kilometers away from
home or whatever okay once you've got
that you're going to substitute those
values into here evaluate it cuts it out
in this pencil would it be 20 and then
off you go you've got your a
displacement function does that make
sense
I'm so glad you asked
so displacement candy zero right
what does that look like here what would
that look like let's uh let's change
some things here okay I don't need that
tangent either a displacement of zero
displacement of zero okay let's just for
the sake of our illustration let's
consider negative time as as if it made
sense okay so where would be a couple of
points in time
that from the beginning to the end I end
up with displacement zero can someone
give me an example
how about okay go ahead and pick a value
that's not on there okay my axis only
goes up the name of whatever deciding so
how about a justify Darren's numbers by
three cuz it's hard to do really good
his negative one there's a stopping
point if I compare that now with Taiwan
I've gone all the way down to here and
then I've come up and I've ended here
right so this total displacement zero
I've ended back where I started what
does that mean for the velocity function
what area do you get when you integrate
this guy from negative one to one answer
because this is an integral right sorry
because this line here it's integral
it's a vector it takes into account
negatives and positives right before we
were trying to solve the pull of area
that's been finicky that you ended up
with negative things right but you want
negative things because this area down
here represents I'm going well back home
I'm going to the left I'm going down I'm
going in the negative direction this
area here this area here they cancel out
which is why total displacement is zero
because the the integral with the area
the integral is zero so that's why
there's no displacement does that make
sense
simple idea but I just wanted you to get
to get that across because what I learnt
this I just learnt this you just do this
and have no connection with your
actually working out an area and that
area I promise this will be the last
time I do it that area is exactly what
you've been doing since like what year
eight when you virt distance equals
speed times time just doing it an
infinite number of times and that's what
integration is